do you think back and say to yourself
wow i was a part of the rich gang album
one of the most like pivotal yeah
influential projects ever yeah i was
excited to be a part of the whole
moments where like rachel me and thug
were popping that's what i'm saying cuz
i was around all those in those studio
sessions and just like you know miss
that wave it was though so you were in
the sessions with rich homie and uh and
young yeah they did that like milk marie
one in orlando that [ __ ] was sold they
did that one in the studio uh the studio
that i recorded in orlando yeah i was
there i was there when they made [ __ ]
lifestyle really yeah what was that like
crazy everybody knew there was a hit
bird was like this is the one like we
all just were like who took the lead on
lifestyle as far as like
stuck came up with the medallion
everything yeah he's yeah he did his
thing and i only laid his first but yeah
that was just that's just a dope error
to be around like i don't know i was
like soaking up game at that time like
just kind of just you know i was that's
a pretty big deal to say you were at the
lifestyle session yeah it's dope
birdman was there yep everyone knew yeah
right yeah like doug had a lot of dope
records like he had bro records that
didn't come out to like slime season
three or four or three that that were
dope um
so like he had all these records playing
but they were trying to find that like
real single that took it off and i don't
know burke got a crazy year for music he
was like the second they made it he was
like this is the one we're shooting the
video it's over